foreign
expert or just curious about the new and
exciting development you won't want to
miss this discussion about the latest AI
sensation I'm talking about chat gbt a
highly Advanced language model based on
gpt3 technology developed by open AI
chat GPT is a state of art language
generation AI model that has captured
the attention of millions of people
around the world it has been trained on
a massive data set of text Data making
it one of the most largest language
models to date but do you know a new
version of GPD is coming up it's called
gpd4 and it will support up to 1
trillion parameters compared to 175
billion parameters of gpt3 now you might
be wondering what are these parameters
so what it means when a user sends a
query to the newer version of star GPT
then it will process that query with all
1 training parameters to deliver a
correct and suitable response isn't it
mind-blowing not only that gpt4 will
have more applications than its
predecessor gpt3 the gpt3 has various
applications like text generation Tech
summarization automated content
generation application and is also being
used by various companies like viable
Fable studio and algolia aside from its
remarkable language handling ability
gpt4 has the possibility of being
utilized for additional functions such
as generating images and videos this is
due to the fact gpt4 is constructed
using the Transformer architecture which
has demonstrated Effectiveness in
multiple machine learning assignments
including computer vision psychologist
and cognitive scientist Gary marker said
that he can guarantee that GPT 4 will
blow the mines He also mentioned that
gpt4 will totally Eclipse chair gbt as
it has more parameters and is being
trained with more data however the CEO
Sam Altman debunks false information
surrounding the company's upcoming chair
gpt4 Altman said that he did not have an
actual AGI that is an artificial general
intelligence that could travel humans in
learning and existence
the release of chat GPT and other AI
powered chatbots had has a major impact
on Google search business with the New
York Times reporting that it prompted
Google's management to declare State
emergency referred to as code red gpt4
with its improved complexity and quicker
response time has the potential to
enhance communication by making it more
natural and accurate for instance short
sentence responses from a chat board can
reduce the likelihood of people clicking
on ads this AI technology could bring
about a major transformation in the
economy Google employees have been
assigned the task of developing AI
products with gpt4 that can match the
capability of gpt3 such as its
capability of generating art music and
other visuals that openai is currently
capable of Microsoft has invested 3
billion dollars into the open Ai and is
reportedly in discussion to invest an
additional 10 billion as deported by the
New York Times the paper also stated
that the release of gpd4 is expected to
take place in the first quarter of 22
three Matt mcelveen a venture capitalist
with the knowledge of GPT 4 hinted that
the new system May possess his
multimodal capabilities which refers to
the capability of functioning in various
modes such as text images and songs the
gpt4 chat board built using Microsoft
extensive data center network has the
potential to be similar to chatgpt
generating only text or it could be
incorporate both text and images however
Sam outman has cautioned not to set
expectations too high so at this point
it is difficult to say with certainty
what GPT 4 will look like and what it
will be capable of so what do you think
about chatgpt4 do let us know in the
comment section below now this shows
that AI is one of the most sought out
technology in today's day and age so if
you are aiming to get certified in
artificial intelligence and want to
build an AI engineering career in that
case you can check simply loans
artificial intelligence Masters program
in collaboration with IBM which will
open the doors for the best career
opportunity is to find the details of
Simply an artificial intelligence master
program check the link in the
description box below it could be the
ideal solution to help you build your
career in the right direction
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here